given that you love it and sometimes
maybe lose yourself in the drug of it
how do you find like work life balance
together inside a relationship
like time for each other
I don't it also I'm not a good person I
asked what do you love more uh male or
effect factor factor is a really good
game that's like not a fair comparison
okay you're talking about one of the
best cleanest games best support ever
made cleanest code base like yeah this
is
yeah it's more factorial time for me
starting to understand where the
massaging comes from by the way is is
the uh is Vector legit a really good
game yeah of course yeah if you're like
uh do you enjoy programming of course
that's all I do that's all that's okay
if you've got like a programming is is
the game in itself that I enjoy probably
more than anything else but yeah it's
very much a game like that of like if
you're into stuff like that like you can
lose hundreds of hours like very quickly
to like you have a problem and then you
think of a solution and then you iterate
on that over and over and over again in
larger larger schemes sometimes you got
to redesign stuff sometimes you get like
it's very much like that kind of guy
this is essentially building a factory
like what on a foreign planet or
something like that it's basically it's
like a bunch of you're trying to
automate different problems so that you
can build bigger things so that you can
automate bigger problems so you can
build bigger things and automate bigger
problems so it's more complicated than
like a city building game like some City
type of thing I wouldn't say it's more
complicated it's more like it's like
factorials like a game of like logic
like strictly like logic like it's
almost like building a circuit or
something yes yeah there's like their
circuitry and you've got your an orgs
organized you like there's stuff like
that it's very much like that like what
are the enemies in the game like what um
they're like try to bite you and you can
get guns and shoot and kill them but as
I saw there's like shooting going on
yeah but that's like a minor other
problem to solve in the game basically
yeah okay all right so you see what we
did there we just started talking about
the game as we're trying oh my God
that's like a game okay that's that's
horrible anyway is there is that
basically the struggle not stop struggle
how to get human
like intimate human time
I feel like it was like a little bit
more in the past I feel like it's been
better lately but I think it's because
um when we started dating I wasn't
streaming and I kind of just like gave
up like my trip in New Zealand I give up
like like I left Sweden so I was just
like in LA which I hate I hate L.A I
don't like it at all uh it's hard to
make friends that are like real that are
into the same stuff as you it's it was
just really hard for me to connect with
anyone especially also like being a
European and like being around Americans
was very strange so the only thing I had
when I came here was him
and I um and I didn't expect the
situation because yeah because we had we
had like two weeks of hanging out and
like he would be in his computer
sometimes and like do emails and stuff
but I wasn't thinking that he would
stream like 12 hours a day and it was
pretty like it was pretty intense like
in the beginning of it as well and I
realized it was really hard to like get
attention and get time because his like
love meter would be like full if I was
just in the house and that's just kind
of like the way he is and for me back
then when I didn't have anything else to
do
um was kind of like a it was kind of
crazy uh for me I feel like right now
because I do work as well and I have
things going from for me and I have
other friends uh now that I made I feel
like it's a lot easier because and and I
can definitely like enjoy just like
being in separate rooms and just like
hear him in the background is really
nice I can I I can sit and paint and
like in my room and I will do that for
hours while I'm just like hearing a
scream in the background it's kind of
like comforting that he's he's just
there and it feels nice I like it
because to you that's the sound of
Happiness yes because I know he's right
there yeah it's nice and they'll come in
and check on me sometimes and it's it's
kind of like it's actually very
comforting it's very nice I like it yeah
I think that's kind of what a
relationship is like you do fun things
together you know you share moments
together but also just like having
someone like around you is really really
nice uh and I think that's probably
maybe it's me growing up maybe that's
what it is and like I start liking like
the kind of I feel like we're like an
old couple like we're like 80 and we're
just like around we don't really have to
talk much it's it's nice that fills you
Your Love Meter
um
I need both I mean okay you meant you're
making it sound like that I'm like
craving like I haven't said anything I'm
not saying anything I have a sub single
thing I know exactly what you're
thinking so much judging going on
there's no judgment um no but like we I
think I think whenever we do plan
something out like if we if we go on a
trip like every other month or once a
month uh I feel like usually like that's
enough as long as he's not playing
Victoria the entire time like if I feel
like he's going on these trips with me
and he's not
like doing things for me or he's done
he's not interested in like spending
time or like being present with me then
I feel like I just feel like I'm just
wasting time right now and then I get
kind of disappointed but otherwise I
think this like this is fun I think this
is like spending time together because
we're like doing something together yeah
it's fun yeah my love meter is full it's
my social life we like to we like to
think about it that way that like I need
like a little bit more of like this one
thing like quality time then he needs
like almost zero quality time but like
let's say that we took away like
physical touch you would probably not be
very happy
um so you need physical touch so it's
not just Factoria huh no I'm a very
kindly person yeah like cuddly and then
you're like I guess like acts of service
like if I do something for you get
really happy like hot chocolate yeah
like if I give him hot chocolate in the
morning he gets really happy so the
actual it's not the hot chocolate it's
the giving of the hot chocolate no it's
just a hot chocolate but if she gives it
to me I didn't have to get away is it
just physical touch to you like that's
really nice
all right well if you have to choose
between Factoria and the drama
or political discourse which probably
political discourse probably my calling
but I am a good factorial player
like what role exactly does factorial
play in your streaming life oh well
right now it's just usually there are
like these games that I play in the
background as I have conversation
because it's hard for me to sit on the
computer just talk and not like be
playing a game at the same time so it's
just something to keep me kind of like
occupied you know some people buy like
those little like widget things I guess
yeah that's what yours yeah basically
yeah it's like Minecraft or factorio for
me
all right well my love meter is full
from this well thank you so much for
joining us this is really fun um you
guys are fascinating human beings
um thank you for existing I'm glad to
live in a world where you exist and I
can't wait to see what kind of beautiful
uh thing you create next and the crazy
kind of art that you create through the
different people you interact with
Destiny Steven you're an amazing human
thank you so much for talking to me it's
an honor hope to talk with you again
talking to Ben Shapiro you've given me a
lot of inspiration it's an honor to talk
to the Ben Shapiro of the left yeah well
thanks a lot for having me I appreciate
it thank you guys thank you